et c'est la fin de ce journal on passe
tout de suite si tout de suite pardon à
la chasse aux faux seins faux
[Musique]
info intox et avec vous anthony st léger
bonjour bonjour à peine bonjour à tous
et on s'intéresse toujours à la guerre
en ukraine terrain fertile aux fausses
informations exemple ce soit avec la
syrie d'azov talent à marioupol ses lacs
sont réfugiés les derniers civils et
militaires qui défendent la ville
l'ukrainien bien sûr assiégée par les
russes effectivement et la fox l'une des
enfants que ce soit elle concerne que
précisément un homme que l'on va
découvrir ses trésors qu à dieu c'est
lui que vous voyez à l'écran c'est un
ancien lieutenant général canadien
ancien car il a pris sa retraite en
octobre 2021 après des accusations de
mauvais comportements sexuels le réduire
en fait prendre le commandement de
l'armée canadienne un mois avant en
septembre 2021 donc alors pourquoi il
nous intéresse parce que sa présence en
ukraine elle est avérée il s'y est
envolé le 5 avril pour combattre l'armée
russe aux côtés des soldats zouk régna
et plusieurs publications affirment ces
derniers jours qu'il fait partie du
millier selon les estimations du millier
de soldats ukrainien présent retranchés
dans l'usiné of talent publication que
l'on retrouve essentiellement dans des
groupes ou des pages facebook dans en
afrique de l'ouest dont celle ci par
exemple avec cette photo qui est censée
illustrer son arrestation par les forces
russes azoff s'installe donc à marioupol
et vous voyez donc la déclaration guerre
en ukraine il est capturé et ils se
seraient ils auraient même tenté de
s'échapper par un dégoût selon cette
publication donc c'est tout d'où
vient-elle anthony alors la réponse est
les données vous êtes habitués
maintenant c'est un grand classique avec
à la recherche d' image inversée en
l'occurrence a grâce à google images
elles nous ramènent à un reportage de la
télé publique russe vesti nous sommes le
24 février vous reconnaissez à l'image
en question 24 février le jour où tout a
commencé cette guerre en ukraine il ya
plus de deux mois deux mois et demi mais
maintenant on est loin donc d'azov
talent et ses hommes ce sont des
militaires des forces armées
ukrainiennes qui se sont rendus près du
village de pétrissent caisse et c'est
pas très loin de kiev alors les rumeurs
autour de trevor cadieux elles
fleurissent retour depuis le 28 avril
depuis que le représentant officiel de
la milice populaire de la république de
dounia issa annoncé la possible présence
d'un général de l'armée canadienne mais
sans mentionner de noms alors oui trevor
cadieux et bien en ukraine je voulais
dit mais pas de preuve qu'il soit à
marioupol et pas de preuve non plus ni
de version officielle quant à son
arrestation alors ces rumeurs elles ne
sont pas sans rappeler celle qui on
cible il ya quelques semaines roger
cloutier un responsable de l'otan un
lieutenant général américain de l'otan
qui aurait été arrêté le 6 à marioupol
une information et des photos utilisées
pour montrer l'encore erronée l'ukraine
toujours des publications insinue que la
pologne s'apprête à envoyer des troupes
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine effectivement
à l'instar de ce post facebook que l'on
découvre ensemble qui infirme nom que la
pologne se prépare à envahir l'ukraine
etc utilisent cette vidéo alors vous
voyez si une capture d'écran et la vidéo
regardez elle reprend le format de celle
publiée par la bbc vous avez le logo
évidemment mais également à la fois la
typographie la police et les sous titres
en question alors d'où viennent ces
images et bien elles nous viennent tout
droit d'un autre média britannique de
sun ici par exemple on retrouve la même
image que la capture d'écran on est en
fait le 8 avril et vous le voyez cet
écrit ici c'est écrit ici dans le titre
il s'agit d'un exercice conjoint entre
les états unis et la pologne en pologne
d'autres images dans la vidéo virale
nous montre des tanks celles ci viennent
cette fois d'une autre d'un autre
reportage de sun on est le 1er mars et
vous le voyez il s'agit d'un
entraînement de l'otan en pologne en
estonie et en allemagne dans le faux
reportage de la bbc il ya aussi un
document c'est celui-ci qui est utilisé
pour attester l'idée qu'il l'aurait bien
cette attaque de la pologne en ukraine
il s'agit de ce document donc un ordre
de préparation de l'armée signé par le
commandement commandant en chef de
l'armée polonaise mais c'est un faux une
contrefaçon c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
confirmé le commandement général
polonais des forces armées sur son
compte twitter et si vous d'un peu plus
près la signature et bien ça c'est un
document officiel
voilà la signature en question et voilà
la fosse est signature absolument rien à
voir donc depuis le début de la guerre
en ukraine le fait d'utiliser les codes
des médias officiels comme ici la bbc ou
même de sources sérieuses pour diffuser
des infos que ça se développe de plus en
plus mais c'est quelque chose d'assez un
courant finalement c'est un procédé
assez courant je vous renvoie d'ailleurs
aux différents articles des observateurs
présents sur notre site sur le sujet
merci anthony st léger info ou intox est
terminée nom se retrouve dans trois
minutes - un nouveau journal d'en parler
direct
[Musique]